the Rings we might get from something
the size of the Moon would be about five
thousand kilometers wide and around nine
and a half kilometers thick
but unlike Saturn's icy Rings ours would
be made of nothing but Rock the Earth is
just too close to the Sun to keep the
debris iced
looking out of the sky you'd be able to
see these rings from Earth at all times
because of the brightness of the Rings
the moon wouldn't seem as bright anymore
that is if we still had the moon if the
moon crumbled up and became our Rings
well there'd be nothing else up there to
look at and there would be some other
consequences
the Rings suddenly hugging Earth would
disrupt internal navigation systems of
some animals
if not enough direct sunlight was making
it through the Rings they would also
affect photosynthesis and our oxygen
supply